[Music]
so
let me help you
the touch please that
[Music]
oh now you're gonna sit here and act all
innocent like you didn't do anything
wrong
really really every time i try
to talk to you you just tell me to shut
up i can't
stop acting all innocent florian i'm
doing the best i can to make
everything happen for us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
today while we're moving into the hotel
i saw a video
online with florian
sitting on the bed in the room with the
same girl that posted those pictures
[Music]
this video is making me feel like
i have more unanswered questions
what happened in that room when i
confronted him about it
he just doesn't want to bud she just
doesn't want to talk about it what was
he doing in her room and in her bed and
i want to know is there any more is
there any other pictures any other video
what if there's something else out there
that she's gonna post later
what if there's one of them like kissing
her or more worse naked
you know there was pictures
before and we talked it out and
i let that go although i still had trust
issues i still
believed him
i thought everything was out in the open
i thought he told me everything
but i guess not and
and that's the hard part to accept
you